for almost a year jonathan tebe a u.s
navy nuclear engineer and his wife diana
a high school humanities teacher at a
prestigious private annapolis high
school sold top secret information
concerning the design of the u.s navy's
virginia-class nuclear-powered warships
in exchange for cryptocurrency to a
person they thought was representing a
foreign power in fact that person was an
undercover fbi agent
the couple lived in a quiet neighborhood
in annapolis and drove a mini cooper
they didn't talk to anybody even on the
block they moved here in 2014 and been
up and down this block so many times and
we would see them and
never even say hi don't even like catch
your eye the navy nuclear engineer had a
high level security clearance and worked
for the top secret naval reactors
program near the pentagon in april 2020
he sent the first package of classified
documents to a foreign government which
passed the information back to a u.s
defense attache suggesting the country
may have been an ally i apologize for
this poor translation into your language
please forward this letter to your
military intelligence agency i believe
this information will be of great value
to your nation this is not a hoax
the criminal complaint says tebay
visited washington d.c over memorial day
posing as a tourist and asked his
handlers to fly a flag signal from the
roof of their embassy to indicate he was
talking to the right people and not the
u.s government at the first dead drop in
west virginia quote the fbi recovered a
blue 16 gigabyte sandisk sd card left by
jonathan tebe at the dead drop location
the sd card was wrapped in plastic and
placed between two slices of bread on a
half of a peanut butter sandwich the
half sandwich was housed inside of a
plastic bag
tebe and his wife were arrested on
saturday in west virginia where they
will be in court tomorrow they have two
children the couple could face life in
prison hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else